henry kissinger praises your new book
and you thank him in it in the
dedication
what's your relationship like with him
what makes him interesting
maybe what makes him controversial what
makes him such a central figure in
history the first most importantly he's
unique about seeing things through all
the others eyes
um so if you were
it's like there's a chess game i mean i
think geopolit geopolitics
is like a chess game but with multiple
chess players playing the same game yes
so imagine there are
six people around playing the chess game
and he could sit in each seat
and he could know how they see it
okay and see it in a calm way of how
they see it he's unique in that way he's
98 years old and he's equally able to do
that
and he has a background
that in which he's a historian so he
really understands history
super terrifically
he doesn't understand economic history
as much so that's why to some extent we
enjoy having a conversation because he's
interested in the act and in the
economic piece he doesn't know and i'm
so interested in the geopolitical piece
that i don't know as well but anyway
he's able to do that but not only a
historian but a practitioner
so when you go from an academic
to a practitioner
who has that talent to see things
through others eyes in an objective way
and to be strategic rather than just
tactical
that's a very special person and that's
why henry is uh to me a very special
person yeah he's lived a fascinating
life
just all all of the world events he's
been involved in is fascinating and like
you said that's such an interesting
skill to have to consider what are the
concerns the hope the dreams the fears
of the all the people at the table what
are they thinking
i i find that people don't
once again don't do that enough when
it's the obvious thing you should be
doing whether it's business deals or
um political negotiation or geopolitical
negotiation
i'm often surprised again sorry to go to
the russian thing because i i i hear
sort of like i hear putin talk in
russian
and you start to infer certain
intentions and like not the trivial
stuff like the human being what is
what is that human being hoping for
himself for his country
for his close inner circle for the
bigger
like and i i just see that that's often
just lost in translation i just see like
american leaders talking to putin
and it's just not
it's there's not a connection absolutely
i know exactly what you're talking about
you i it has never failed
that in my listening to a conversation
and or even reading a speech
or
and you see then it reported
the inevitably the reporter
picked some
headline characterization
that has very little to do with what was
really happening but might be a headline
grabber that's at some kind of
distortion and there's a lack of
understanding of really what's going on
you